that'd be worse analogy really so good
basically we're gonna try food and guess
whether it's instant or fresh I love in
some food because it's so easy to make
and it's so quick you're the opposite
recently we've been on a diet and we've
been eating more fresh things and so now
I feel like we'll be able to distinguish
what is instant and what is fresh I'm
actually very excited about this because
so many people hate on instant food I
feel like that's not how foods supposed
to come at all this consistency feels
like consistent throughout yeah this
looks like it has it's like makeup
honest foundation that's like ready the
legs
strike a pose like it just came from the
farm because the character was it nice
that's tasty yeah for the record instant
food can taste good you should either
just do your test that's homemade that
this one's instant it was this one mmm
yes fresh this one is instant
[Music]
powdered eggs why oh you can't really
tell delicious also delicious
I would eat both what do you thin stick
agree Fang these are real I'm gonna go
this is the real my guess is opposite to
him if I can they both taste good it's
probably more effort to make powdered
egg than like a real scrambled egg
yeah you just cook it I used to eat
instant mac and cheese all the time in
college right off about I think because
of the color that this one is probably
the fake one but I think that the
instant one is yummier it looks like it
has melted from LT or cheese on it like
easy cheese like clearly have more love
this is what I'm gonna eat my words this
has to be like something like Kraft or
something you know that was my jam
growing up my brother I used to fight
over the last bowl this is like some
real cheese [ __ ] look at that you know
it's real one than sheep and stuck
together this is better though it just
is how much to like grew up on this
something and something with your
brother can you not do that with this
point yes you can is this instant for
sure your real food isn't usually like
that right in color this is wrong
oh so there are two different types of
noodles so it's hard
you made it hard on us man it's really
good
see how are the little is like folding
weirdly which means it's probably
instant yeah wait I'm just gonna go with
YB on this I'm gonna go with the white
noodles as instant this is instant wait
you have five seconds five four three
two we're not potatoes baby no I love
instant food I think great name is Venus
don't know what about it perishing the
boo-boom perish but you might it's a
good balance to have like you know fresh
food too
no matter if we're on a diet or not
please still know our food I do want to
finish that mac and cheese though I do
want to finish those noodles
[Music]